J'ai vraiment peur. Je ne crois pas qu'on y arrivera.
Vous avez probablement déjà tous vu l'étonnante présentation d'Al Gore.
Peu après l'avoir vu, nous avons invité des amis à diner en famille.
La conversation en est venue au réchauffement climatique,
et tout le monde était d'accord : c’est un vrai problème.
Nous avons une crise climatique.
Nous avons fait un tour de table pour trouver quoi faire.
La conversation arriva à ma fille de 15 ans, Mary.
Elle dit « Je suis d'accord avec tout ce que vous avez dit.
J'ai peur et je suis en colère. » Puis elle s'est tournée vers moi et dit :
« Papa, ta génération a créé ce problème, tu ferais mieux de le régler. » Wow.
La conversation s'arrêta. Tous les yeux se sont tournés vers moi.
(Rires)
Je ne savais pas quoi dire. La 2e loi de Kleiner est :
« Il y a un moment où la panique est la bonne réaction. »
(Rires)
Et nous l'avons atteint. Nous ne pouvons plus sous-estimer ce problème.
Si nous faisons face à des conséquences irréversibles et catastrophiques,
nous devons agir de manière décisive.
Je dois vous le dire, pour moi, tout a changé ce soir-là.
Mes associés et moi, nous nous sommes donnés comme mission d'en savoir plus,
pour essayer de faire bien plus. Nous nous sommes mobilisés, avons pris l'avion.
Nous sommes allés au Brésil, en Chine et en Inde,
à Netonville en Arkansas, et à Washington D.C. et à Sacramento.
Je voudrais vous dire ce que nous avons appris de ces voyages.
Parce que plus nous en apprenions, plus l'inquiétude grandissait.
Vous savez, nous sommes des réseauteurs boulimiques alors quand on voit un gros problème ou une occasion
comme la grippe aviaire ou les médicaments personnalisés,
nous rassemblons les gens les plus intelligents de notre connaissance.
Pour cette crise climatique, nous avons bâti un réseau, vraiment,
de superstars ; des activistes législatifs aux scientifiques, aux entrepreneurs et aux leaders d'affaires ; une cinquantaine.
Je veux vous dire ce que nous y avons appris
et quatre leçons que j'ai apprises l'année dernière.
La première : les entreprises sont vraiment puissantes,
et cela compte beaucoup.
Voici comment Wal-Mart est devenue verte, et ce que cela veut dire : il y deux ans, le PDG, Lee Scott, se dit
qu'être vert était le prochain grand enjeu, et donc Wal-Mart en a fait une priorité.
Ils s'engagèrent, pour leurs magasins existants, à en réduire la consommation énergétique de 20 %,
et de 30 % dans leurs nouveaux magasins, tout cela en sept ans.
Les gros consommateurs d'énergie y sont le chauffage et l'air conditionné, puis l'éclairage, puis le froid.
Regardez cela : ils ont peint les toits en blanc,
ils ont mis des lucarnes dans leurs magasins pour récolter la lumière naturelle et réduire l'artificielle,
enfin, ils ont mis les produits froids sous porte fermée, éclairés par des LED.
C'est vrai, pourquoi essayer de réfrigérer tout le magasin ?
Des solutions simples, astucieuses, basées sur des technologies existantes.
Pourquoi Wal-Mart compte ? La taille.
C'est le premier employeur privé d'Amérique. C'est le premier consommateur privé d'électricité.
Ils ont la seconde flotte de véhicules sur les routes.
Et ils ont l'une des chaines de fournisseurs les plus étonnantes,
60 000 fournisseurs. Si c'était un pays,
il serait le 6e partenaire économique de la Chine.
Et peut-être plus important encore, ils ont de l'influence auprès des autres sociétés.
Quand Wal-Mart dit qu'il devient vert et qu'il en bénéficiera,
cela a un fort impact sur les autres institutions.
Comprenez-le bien, quand Wal-Mart atteindra 20 % de réduction d'énergie,
cela sera un changement capital. Mais je crains que cela ne suffise pas.
Nous avons besoin que Wal-Mart et toutes les autres sociétés le fassent.
La 2ème chose que nous avons apprise est que les individus comptent,
ils comptent énormément.
J'ai une autre histoire de Wal-Mart.
Wal-Mart a plus de 125 millions de clients aux États-Unis, soit le tiers de sa population.
65 millions d'ampoules fluorescentes ont été vendues l'an dernier.
Et Wal-Mart s'est engagé à en vendre
encore 100 millions dans l'année à venir. Mais ce n'est pas facile.
Les clients les aiment peu.
La lumière est un peu bizarre, elles ne s'atténuent pas, ne démarrent pas instantanément.
Mais le bénéfice est vraiment énorme.
100 millions d'ampoules fluorescentes signifient
une économie d'énergie de 600 millions de dollars,
et 20 millions de tonnes de CO2 par an, année après année.
C'est difficile de faire bien consommer.
Il est stupide d'utiliser deux tonnes d'acier, verre et plastique pour trainer nos pauvres êtres dans les centres commerciaux.
Il est stupide de mettre de l'eau en bouteilles plastiques aux Fiji et de les envoyer ici.
(Rires)
C'est dur de changer le comportement des consommateurs, parce qu'ils ignorent combien cela coûte. Le savez-vous ?
Combien de CO2 avez-vous générés pour arriver jusqu'ici ?
Je ne sais pas, et je le devrais.
Ceux d'entre nous qui s'en soucient agiraient mieux si nous savions les coûts réels.
Mais tant que nous prétendons que le CO2 est gratuit,
tant que son utilisation est quasi invisible, comment attendre un changement ?
Je suis vraiment effrayé, parce que je pense que le genre de changements qu'il est raisonnable d'attendre des individus
ne sera manifestement pas assez.
La 3ème leçon est que la politique compte. Vraiment.
En fait, elle est primordiale.
Il y a une anecdote à propos de notre réseau.
À la fin de notre 1ère réunion, nous avons parlé ensemble des actions à entreprendre, des suites à donner.
Et Bob Epstein a levé la main. Il s'est levé.
Bob est le techno de Berkeley qui a fondé Sybase.
Eh bien, Bob dit que le plus important à faire maintenant
était de rendre bien clair à Sacramento, en Californie,
que nous avons besoin d'un système de marché de mandats pour limiter et réduire les gaz à effet de serre en Californie.
C'est nécessaire et tout aussi important, c'est bon pour l'économie californienne.
Alors, huit d'entre nous y sont allés rencontrer
les sept législateurs indécis et nous avons fait campagne pour la loi AB32.
Vous savez quoi ? Six d'entre eux ont voté pour,
elle est donc passée par 47 voix contre 32.
(Applaudissements)
S'il vous plait, non. Merci.
C'est la loi la plus importante de 2006 : La Californie était le premier État à décider
une baisse de 25 % des gaz à effet de serre d'ici à 2020.
Et cela créera 83 000 nouveaux emplois,
4 milliards de dollars de revenu annuel, et une réduction des émissions de CO2
de 174 millions de tonnes par an.
La Californie émet 7 % du CO2 des États-Unis.
Cela ne réduira que de 1,5 % les émissions de CO2 du pays.
C'est un bon début, mais je dois dire que je crains vraiment,
je suis certain, que la Californie ce n'est pas assez.
Et voici une histoire de politique nationale dont nous pouvons tous apprendre.
Tom Friedman a dit : « Si vous n'y allez pas, vous ne savez pas. »
Nous sommes allés au Brésil voir le Dr. Jose Goldemberg.
C'est le père de la révolution de l'éthanol.
Il nous a dit que le gouvernement brésilien obligea les stations-services du pays à avoir de l'éthanol.
Et ils obligèrent les nouveaux véhicules à être compatibles avec les deux carburants,
ils rouleraient à l'éthanol ou à l'essence ordinaire.
Et voici ce qui s'est produit au Brésil. Ils ont maintenant 29 000 pompes à éthanol,
contre 700 aux États-Unis, dont 2 dérisoires en Californie,
et en trois ans leur parc de véhicules compatible est passé de 4 % à 85 %.
Aux États-Unis, 5 % sont compatibles.
Et vous savez quoi ? Leur propriétaire l'ignore en général.
Ce qui s'est produit au Brésil, c'est un remplacement
de 40 % de l'essence pour véhicules par de l'éthanol.
Depuis 1975, cela fait 59 milliards de dollars qu'ils n'ont pas envoyés au Moyen-Orient.
Cela a créé un million d'emplois dans leur pays,
et économisé 32 millions de tonnes de CO2. C'est considérable.
C'est 10 % des émissions de CO2 du pays.
Mais le Brésil ne fait que 1,3 % des émissions mondiales de CO2.
Alors, je crains que le miracle de l'éthanol brésilien ne soit pas assez.
En fait, je crains que toutes nos meilleures politiques ne soient pas assez.
La 4ème et dernière leçon porte sur le potentiel des innovations radicales.
Je veux parler d'un problème tragique et d'une avancée technologique capitale.
Chaque année, un million et demi de gens meurt
d'une maladie totalement évitable : la malaria. 6 000 personnes par jour.
Faute de 2 $ pour des médicaments achetables à la pharmacie du coin.
Eh bien, 2 $, c'est trop pour l'Afrique.
Alors, une équipe de chercheurs de Berkeley, avec 15 millions de dollars
de la fondation Gates, conçoit et réalise une façon radicalement neuve de faire
l'ingrédient clé : l'artemisinine,
et ils produiront ces médicaments 10 fois moins cher. Ils sauveront au moins un million de vies par an.
Leur avancée est la biologie synthétique.
Cela s'appuie sur des millions d'années d'évolution en re-concevant des insectes pour produire utile.
Il faut entrer dans le microbe,
changer sa voie métabolique, et vous obtenez une usine chimique vivante.
Vous pouvez me demander :
John, quel rapport avec être vert et la crise climatique ?
Un grand rapport.
Nous avons formé une société appelée Amyris, et cette même technologie peut servir à améliorer les biocarburants.
Ne passons pas rapidement là-dessus. C'est vraiment considérable.
Cela signifie que nous pouvons concevoir les molécules dans la chaîne des carburants
en les optimisant au passage.
Alors, si tout va bien, nous aurons des insectes dans des bacs chauffés
qui mangeront et digéreront des sucres pour excréter de meilleurs biocarburants.
Une vie meilleure grâce aux insectes !
Alan Kay a dit : « Le meilleur moyen de prédire le futur est de l'inventer. »
Et bien sûr, à Kleiner nous ajoutons que le 2nd meilleur moyen est de le financer.
C'est pourquoi nous investissons 200 millions de dollars
dans une large gamme de technologies neuves disruptives, innovantes en technologies vertes.
Et nous y encourageons d'autres. Nous en parlons beaucoup.
En 2005, 600 millions de dollars ont été investis dans des technologies neuves
comparables à ce que vous voyez ici. En 2006 cela a doublé à 1,2 milliard de dollars.
Mais je crains que nous ayons besoin de plus, bien plus.
Pour référence, fait nº 1 : les revenus en 2005 d'Exxon étaient d'un milliard par jour.
Saviez-vous qu'ils n'en investissent que 0,2 % en R & D (recherche et développement) ?
Fait nº 2 : le nouveau budget du président pour l'énergie renouvelable fait à peine un milliard de dollars au total.
Moins d'un jour des revenus d'Exxon.
Fait nº 3 : je parie que vous ne saviez pas qu'il y assez d'énergie sous les roches chaudes du pays pour subvenir à ses besoins énergétiques
pour le prochain millénaire.
Le budget fédéral compte 20 misérables millions de R & D pour l'énergie géothermique.
Il est quasi criminel que nous n'investissions pas plus
dans la recherche énergétique dans ce pays.
Et j'ai vraiment peur que cela ne soit absolument pas assez.
En une année d'apprentissage, nous avons trouvé des surprises.
Qui aurait cru qu'une chaîne de supermarché ferait du profit en étant verte ?
Qu'un entrepreneur de base de données transformerait la Californie par la loi ?
Qui aurait cru que le miracle de l'éthanol
viendrait d'un pays en développement d'Amérique du Sud ?
Et qui aurait cru que des scientifiques essayant de guérir la malaria feraient des percées en biocarburant ?
Et qui aurait cru que tout cela ne soit pas assez ?
Pas assez pour stabiliser le climat.
Pas assez pour éviter que la glace du Groenland parte dans l'océan.
Les scientifiques nous disent — et ce n'est que conjecture — que nous devons réduire nos émissions de moitié, aussi vite que possible.
Nous en avons peut-être la volonté politique aux États-Unis, mais nous n'avons qu'une seule atmosphère,
il faudra trouver la volonté politique de faire cela sur tout le globe. L'imprévisible dans ce jeu est la Chine.
Pour soupeser le problème, les émissions de CO2 de la Chine font 3,3 Gigatonnes,
les États-Unis font 5,8. Continuer ainsi signifie
que nous aurons 23 Gigatonnes chinoises en 2050.
C'est environ toute la quantité de CO2 au monde.
Continuer ainsi, c'est aller dans le mur.
Quand j'étais à Davos, le maire chinois de Dalian était questionné sur leur stratégie de CO2, et il a dit :
« Vous savez, les Américains utilisent 7 fois plus de CO2 par tête que nous.
Pourquoi la Chine sacrifierait-elle sa croissance afin que l'occident continue à être débauché et stupide ? »
Quelqu'un à une réponse pour lui ? Moi pas.
Nous devons en faire une question économique, pour que tous les peuples et toutes les nations
rendent le bon dénouement profitable, et donc probable.
L'énergie pèse 6000 milliards de dollars sur Terre. C'est la mère de tous les marchés. Vous souvenez-vous d'Internet ?
Eh bien je vais vous dire : les technologies vertes, être vert, c'est plus gros que l'Internet.
Cela pourrait être la plus grande occasion économique du 21e siècle.
De plus, si nous y arrivons,
ce sera la transformation la plus importante pour la vie sur terre depuis que l'atmosphère est passée de méthane à oxygène.
Maintenant, voilà la question difficile, si la trajectoire de toutes
les sociétés, les individus, les politiques et les innovations du monde
ne sont pas assez, que ferons-nous ? Je ne sais pas.
Chacun ici veut prendre soin de changer le monde et a fait une différence d'une façon ou d'une autre.
Alors, mon appel à l'action pour vous
est que vous fassiez du virage au vert votre priorité, votre job actuel.
Que faire ? Vous pouvez personnellement vivre sans carbone.
Allez sur ClimateCrisis.org ou CarbonCalculator.com (ou CompensationCO2.fr ou ActionCarbone.org - n.d.t.)
et achetez des crédits-carbone. Rejoignez d'autres pour légiférer,
faites campagne pour une réduction et un marché des gaz à effet de serre aux États-Unis.
Il y a 6 propositions de loi au Congrés. Faisons-en passer une.
Ce que vous pouvez faire de plus important est d'utiliser pouvoir personnel et Rolodex
pour amener votre société, votre institution, à devenir verte.
Faites comme Wal-Mart, faites-la devenir verte pour ses clients, ses fournisseurs, et pour elle.
Pensez vraiment en dehors des cadres.
Pouvez-vous imaginer ce que cela serait si Amazon ou eBay ou Google
ou Microsoft ou Apple devenait vraiment vert, et cela, grâce à vous ?
Cela pourrait dépasser Wal-Mart.
Je suis impatient de voir ce que les TEDsteurs feront contre cette crise.
Et j'espère vraiment, vraiment que nous multiplierons nos énergies,
tous nos talents et toute notre influence pour résoudre ce problème.
Si nous le faisons, je peux attendre avec impatience
de reprendre cette conversation avec ma fille dans 20 ans.
(Applaudissements)